let's go to the on-chain uh the on-chain
cost basis right and maybe just talk
through kind of how this has confirmed
bull markets in the past and what you're
seeing here now so you can call this a
couple different things you call it the
cost basis or or realize price or v-wop
um and so it's just you know it's all
saying the same thing so you're you're
looking at a v-wap is a volume weighted
average price you're looking at uh
realize cap which we've talked about
several times is the market
capitalization of bitcoin
based off of the last time that coins
removed and so we can kind of track the
amount of capital inflow coming into the
market
and then we normalize this for just
looking at short-term holders in
specific um as as we mentioned we can we
can look at things
based off of that but cut off that
glasson has 155 days to look at
short-term versus long-term holders um
and so what we see is that like
historically the short-term holder cost
basis or realized price or v-wap um
sorry i know i'm throwing like three
different things in there it's all
saying the same thing
they've all kind of served as uh this is
served as kind of the support band in
bull market so if you go back and look
at 2017 uh you can see these like four
different retests where we came back
down during a correction and tested this
and bounced really nicely off of that
as well as once we broke below that um
in in you know at the end of 2017 that
would have been you know time to time to
be cautious and then once you had this
kind of failed uh retest from the
underside that would have been your your
confirmation that you know we've we've
kind of broken the trend um and so it's
it's you know similar to it's similar to
sober and a lot of things what you can
look at is you know when you break below
some people will say okay you know
that's enough that's enough signal for
me to to you know change my my market
outlook right because we we haven't
broken below this uh you know throughout
the entire bull market now we've clearly
broken trend um but some people who are
a bit more conservative look for okay do
we have confirmation and then they'll
they'll base their opinion off of once
we get that you know failed underside
re-test um and but you know you would
have if you did that you know let's say
you sold uh based off of this you would
have kind of gotten out at the same
price point you just basically sold at
the dead cat instead of instead of you
know as soon as it broke i personally
stand in the camp of i would be looking
for kind of this failed underside retest
because i think you know
kind of the the it's really difficult to
time the exact top um you know you kind
of had these kind of red flags and
caution signals that i think you can you
can be given but
the you know the the last the the last
week or two of parabolic moves are where
the largest portion of that move are
made um and so it's really difficult to
like time that perfectly but where i do
think it's reasonable to kind of um to
to look for an exit is is on that dead
cat move uh and so this is just one of
the you know example of that where you
know we had that failed retest from the
underside of that band and then as we
headed into you know the 2018 uh bear
market we had like three failed retests
from the underside of that once we
finally broke above that's when we came
out of the bottom of the bear uh heading
into that mini 20 you know 2019 uh bull
market whatever you want to call this uh
there's a lot of that was driven by uh
the plus token ponzi where they were
like artificially locking up coins uh
but that's like that's a conversation
for another day uh but then we had this
failed once we broke below we had this
failed underside re-test so that's where
you would have become cautious again
until we once again broke back above um
after march 2020. uh you know you could
see in in september of last year we once
again bounced off uh bounced off of this
and then broke below um heading into may
which would have you know would have
been time to to become cautious as well
and then recently we've bounced back
above this uh you know at the at the end
of september so uh two things a you know
notice that we've gotten back above and
bounced off of this conversely to the
end of 2017 where we had a failed
underside retest
of that right so it's it's showing you
that you know at the end of 2017 that
was confirmation we were heading into a
bear market whereas here as we've
retested uh at the end of september
showing that we're confirmation that
we're back in a bullish trend uh and and
notice too that we have confluence of a
couple things that we that we keep
talking about the end of september
confirmation at the end of september
notice there's several metrics that are
all kind of pointing to that same that
same concept um and that's that's what i
really look for you know you can see one
metric and say okay you know this is
telling you something but
when you have three or four different
things all pointing to the same thing
through something that we call
confluence um you know that's that's
where you can really feel strong about
your opinion when you kind of see that
across the board yeah so that's super
helpful and and the next chart you have
i think is interesting because when you
look at uh the short term holders and
the realized price of the short-term
holders compared to the long-term
holders it provides a pretty symmetrical
uh view of like when you should start
accumulating and when you should be
cautious like how do you think about
this chart
one thing i just wanted to touch on the
last one i just completely forgot to say
was just it's at just so people know
right now it's at 53k um so that's kind
of my my bear market floor i think we
can go below as 50 to 53k um you know
and still hold bull market structure and
that also aligns with the technical
level as well as 53k is the one trillion
dollar market cap threshold for bitcoin
so i think that's a really important
level for bitcoin to kind of hold is
that that 53k level you know we could
wick below but i i generally kind of
stand in the camp of as long as we're
closing daily closes above 53k i don't
really see anything to be concerned
about um but yet so sorry to get into
this chart um you're looking at what we
just looked at which is the short term
holder realized price or cost basis and
then you're comparing that to the
long-term holder realized price or cost
basis
and so you get this really clean
oscillator where what you see is that
whenever the short-term holder realized
price oh you know overextends the
long-term holder aka when short-term
holders are kind of dominating the
market um you can kind of get these
these signals of caution or kind of
overheated signals um for kind of the
the broader market structure so you see
that happening you know the two 2013
double pumps as well as uh in 2017 and
then conversely uh whenever whenever
long-term holder realize price uh goes
below short-term hold the realized price
that's that's a good time to accumulate
because showing long-term holders are
dominating the market the speculators
are leaving um and so as you can see
whenever we kind of cross below that
kind of green area that i highlighted uh
that that's a good time to kind of
average in buys we're sitting in kind of
this funky spot right where we're not
we're very close to the very close to
the accumulation zone never quite uh you
know tap that as well as we never really
reached the overheated zone earlier this
year uh and this is kind of a similar
signature to uh 2013 you know i think
completely different market structure to
2013 but just in the sense that you know
we kind of had this parabolic advance
came back down
almost fully reset that and then kind of
reversed uh so that's why that's what i
highlighted with those two blue circles
uh but do note though it only took three
months for for this oscillator to go
from that kind of reset between the 2013
double pumps uh to coming back above
that overheated zone so you know this
this can happen quicker quicker than
than perhaps that uh you know you you'd
expect but for now we're sitting in uh
healthy territory and we're far from
overheated in that sense and it looks
like we've turned the the corner back
towards kind of where we're headed
towards that caution area or at least
you know a fraction of it do you think
that we could go lower right because it
looks like it's already made that cut
back towards that other zone do you
think that we could go further over the
next two three weeks i mean anything is
possible but you know i think um i think
it would take a lot to you know this
looks at like the real
macro kind of trend if you will or
broader trend so it's going to take a
lot to kind of see any kind of reversal
on this um i i generally kind of stand
in the camp that will probably just see
this start to start to tick up into the
future yeah